marcus mariota how are you Marcus I'm
doing well I'm doing fine let me ask you
I guess straight up we chatted about you
if your ears were burning with Mike Mac
about 15 minutes ago saying that he's
still as bullish about you and your
future as he was when you came out of
Oregon but thinks that you're not a
hundred percent healthy and thus your
game isn't as on point because you can't
use your legs like you're like you're
used to using would you say that's a
fair assessment Marcus yeah I'm I mean
I'll never make an excuse I think we can
in week out across the leaders guys I
have to play with some and you know
that's me too and when it comes down to
it I just gotta find ways to make plays
and put our team in the best situation
possible and how how is this offense
suited to your abilities Marcus well the
coaches do a good job of mixing spread
concepts as well that's being able to
run the football downhill and I think
it's tough on defenses and when we're
rolling when everyone's actually
shooting we've done we've done fairly
well and how do you tip what do you take
out of your your night in Pittsburgh
that we all saw on NFL Network and NBC
last week yeah I just being smarter with
the football I think at times you know
you sit in the pocket I believe I can
make everything I can do every
everything that's asked to me and you
know when it comes down to it maybe the
guys covered just using my legs you know
taking a five-yard gain or even a sack
rather than turning the football over
and you know obviously it can't put our
team in those situations when you turn
over the ball four times it's tough to
win and I definitely learn from it and
be better for me but are you able to run
at full speed right now do you think I'm
getting there I'm getting there okay
Marcus Mariota here on the Rich Eisen
show and in terms of the game for you
now as when you first came out a couple
years ago from Oregon how is that how
have you changed
how are you better formed and fit for
the NFL well I think from you know
college implanted Oregon everything that
we did there weekend and week out just
with the temple that we played team
a tough time disguising and really
getting into different looks on defense
and you know one of the adjustments that
I had to go through in the league was
you know different disguises being able
to move protections and making sure
everyone's run in the same direction and
I think I've gotten better at it
obviously I can I can do a better job
but from where I was coming out of
Oregon to where I'm at now I think I've
learned a lot from this influence so in
terms of coming out of Oregon I'm sure
you hear in the Chip Kelly might be
getting back into the the college game
and how strange would it be if he's back
in the pac-12 but for UCLA Marcus yeah
I'd be different it'd be it'd be really
different but I'm I'm sure coach Kelly
would love the opportunity to coach
again and I think wherever he may go
he'll he'll find some success how often
you talk to him uh every now and then
every now and then he does check in and
you know I always appreciate the fact
that he you know I saw my family or how
I'm doing and you know from that
standpoint he's a good guy and I've
always appreciate everything he's done
for me so the last text you received
from him was this morning saying should
I go to UCLA or Florida right Marcus you
got that today you did not get that text
today damn I guess my information is off
do you have any sense of what he might
be thinking about what he's doing Marcus
you know I just have to say I think
coach Kelly plays his cards close to the
chest and really the only people or a
really the only person that knows what
he's gonna do is him okay now I want to
ask you about Baker Mayfield if I may
you have a vote in the Heisman Trophy
being a winner yourself the conversation
this week has been that maybe just maybe
that wasn't a Heisman Trophy worthy
moment but he had against Kansas and
thus he doesn't deserve the trophy or
should get knocked down a peg or two
where do you stand on that subject
Marcus man I'm on the fence to be honest
with you I think he's done a great job
all year of finding ways to win games
you know and I think being around the
trophy committee and being around just a
culture of those guy
you know I I do think holding yourself
to a higher standard is a part of the
the Heisman Trophy and you know
fortunately he got obviously was in the
heat of the moment and you know that
stuff kind of happens but you know we'll
see as it goes but you know you can't
knock the fact that he's been probably
one of the better players in the country
this year but it's somebody for whom you
know the trophy stands for something
about fair play and high-class you think
that are you on the fence as to whether
that was a disqualifying moment for him
Marcus that's not I mean that's not a
decision you know I'm planning to make
obviously there's any other voters that
may feel differently but you know when
it comes down to it when we have to put
in our votes I'm taking everything in
and you know just make who I think is
the best player and in the country so
who else has caught your eye on that
front oh man I think there's a bunch of
guys that are playing very well he's a
running back from Stanford has played
well Penn State guys also play very well
a sake one right yes absolutely and you
know I for me personally just from
watching from afar I think Lamar's had
had a pretty good year and he's not
getting a lot of love just because of
what's going on with this team but they
got a stud and I think he's played
fairly well this year and how Marcus
Mariota a couple more minutes here with
the Tennessee Titans quarterback here on
the Rich Eisen show how was watching the
Predators do what they did and see how
the town reacted to it how has that been
placed in your mind's eye about trying
to replicate that on the football side
of things with your team Marcus
definitely it was a fun atmosphere to be
part of it was just really enjoyable to
be able to go and watch those guys do
what they do and to play with the
physicality and and the mindset that
they did we'd love to be a part of that
we love to get this city going again and
you know obviously we had a little
hiccup last week but I think we're going
in the right direction we just gotta
continue to take your one week at a time
now were you
are you part of that catfish hiding crew
I mean we're youwere you did you did you
sneak it in the game with Taylor and the
rest of your old linemen where were you
on that I was with them for sure so you
were not part of any capers what you're
saying mark I wouldn't say that but it
was a you know what I we enjoyed it and
we're very very fortunate that they
allowed us to be around the that's and
now tell you know how often do you have
to tell Taylor the lawn just lets you
know he said he's my Michigan guy just
like chill out just let's take it down
from 11 to 10 you ever do that Marcus
you need to do that yeah you know every
now and then but I love the way that guy
plays I love the intensity he plays that
and I think when you have a guy like
that on the offensive line he gets
everybody else going and we're very
privileged to have him I think he's one
of our better players yeah man he came
up to me at halftime in Pittsburgh where
I went up to him and he just looks at me
goes we're gonna have the greatest
comeback ever you just watch it this is
coming right now you know I mean he just
almost knocked me and it was a Rodney
Harrison over to you know obviously you
don't have to tell me about him I just I
just find it funny sometimes that he's
kind of firing your ice in that you know
he's we I love playing with that guides
he's uh he's a lot of fun okay ask him
the poll question before we let Marcus
Mariota out the door yeah Marcus what's
the best Thanksgiving dessert pumpkin
pie apple pie pecan pie or sweet potato
pie where do you where do you land on
this Marcus um I'm gonna go to apple pie
look at that
all-american you are all-american
through and through Marcus so and what
is your Thanksgiving gonna be like walk
me through what that looks like for
somebody is a QB one in the NFL tomorrow
I'll be fairly quiet my girlfriend will
be cooking up dinner and she's got some
family in town and I think what some of
the guys over and I'm just kind of
relaxed watching football and enjoy the
date again LaJuan is he coming tomorrow
I will see I think he's got some plans
okay because I mean if you got old
linemen and you better get like one of
those
pound turkeys okay Marcus you take care
of yourself okay we'll chat soon
sounds good thank you you got it marcus
mariota
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience